bonjour Mick Jager bonjour ça va ça va
super vous parlez français ouais
parfaitement un peu un peu pas trop
d'Argo et pas trop vite on va essayer je
suis pas un expert sur le rock français
je connais Johnny vous arrêterez jamais
oui je fais arrê je vois ça ça don le
futur mais cette année
non alors vous avez contribué à faire du
rock and roll une musique anglaise mais
vous vivez une partie du temps en France
qu'est-ce qu'il y a de rock and roll
dans la France je suis pas un expert sur
le rock français vous écoutez de la
musique française pas beaucoup je
connais Johnny les plus fameux morceau
Johnny les autres artistes français je
connais mais moi je suis une je je je
j'étais aux
États-Unis la moitié de ma vie je
j'habite là et et je suis toujours dans
la musique de Blu je suis toujours de
music country je suis toujours music
rock euh la musique africaine
et et je mélange tout ça pour moi je me
suis demandé c'est quoi le rock and roll
pour vous qu'est-ce que c'est qu'est-ce
qu'il y a DEP c'est genre de musique
quoi assez ancien maintenant il y
a plus de 60 ans peut-être on peut dire
même plus euh
c'est un genre que c'est un genre que il
faut faire quelque chose physique il
faut c'est c'est un genre physique il
faut faire la
batterie c'est pas musique pour pour
pour le
computer on utilise les computers mais
quand même il faut j les batteries il
faut j guitar il faut
chanter et comme comme ça c'est toujours
ouj quelque chose pour les jeunes euh
[Musique]
oui malgré il y a beaucoup des autres
genres de musique plus même plus
populaire vous avez toujours eu pendant
100 ans le pop on a 50 ans de Rap
euh mais le rock ça existe toujours et
mais il faut pour le rock il faut pas
faire trop de répétition il faut avoir
toujours égie il faut
l'énergie et il faut aussi de quelques
mélodie un peu et et il faut pour moi il
faut les paroles assez amusantes alors
c'est quelque chose qu'on retrouve
justement dans ce nouvel album 18 ans
que vos fans l'attendaient un album
inédit des Rolling Stones et c'est très
émouvant parce que dans la musique dans
l'écriture dans le clip qui a été révélé
aussi puis dans les les featuring c'est
comme si c'était toute l'histoire des
Rolling Stones qui revenait est-ce que
c'est peut-être le dernier album
teroling non c'est pas le dernier album
on est on est on
engisté plus que la moitié de la
prochaine parce qu' on a enregistré 23
25 morceau dans
cette séance quoi euh et je vais cré
plusieurs chansons en enregisser pour
faire un deuxè euh prochainement vous
savez ce que je trouve très beau dans
cet album pour moi c'est la fidélité
c'est de voir ressurgir comme ça les
grandes figures des Rolling Stones
notamment comment on fait M Jager pour
entretenir une amitié de 60 ans c'est un
métier mais sa un métier maisit jouer
avec les gens un métier c'est une chose
un peu différent
on reste toujours ami mais quand même il
faut travailler ensemble aussi ça c'est
toujours un peu différent alors oui vous
êtes mon mais il faut il faut que vous
travez bien et il faut être là sur sur
et et jouer bien mais
euh pour nous on on a on a décidé de de
de faire ce disque assez vite alors avec
un deadline c'est j'ai dit on va va
commencer décembre ça va fa tout finir
mixé euh par le jeu de Valentin alord
février 14 février alors et on a on a
fait ça on a fait le enregistrement la
overts mixage et tout ça et dans le
temps et parce que avant on enregistrait
beaucoup de choses mais on n jamais eu
une deadline on nous avons fait un
deadline pour nous Kiss Richards retour
de Bill weyman mais on trouve également
sur cet album Paul mccartner ering star
alors c'est intéressant parce qu'on vous
a toujours un petit peu divisé on s'est
toujours demandé s'il y avait pas une é
entre les Rolling Stones et lesles oui
même lui il a dit rment il a dit une
chose comme je sais pas pourquoi mais il
dit une chose oh r St ils sont un groupe
qui qui qui enregistre les chansons
deautres gens
CAV good CAV et je dis et je Tex
lui je suis pas fâché avec toi euh mais
parce que c'est Don beaucoup de beaucoup
de choses pour ma comédie sur scène je
fais de comédie sur scène sur toi mais
non mais il est très il joue très bien
sur C morceau c'est musique punk un peu
sais et j'ai dit producteur Andy j'ai
dit est-ce qu'il peut jouer ça vraiment
parce que je sais pas assz fort pour ça
il dit oui oui oui ok d'accord mais il
il est là il fait ça très bien mais il y
a eu une rivalité entre les Beatles et
les rollingon toujours ça mais euh c'est
nous sommes tous toujours amis tu sais
je suis très amical avec John mais il
est très drôle ça et PA est
plus différ mais je suis toujours ami
avec lui alors donc si je vous pose la
question qu'on pose à tout le monde
est-ce que vous êtes Beatles ou Rolling
Stones ça c'est aen question de des
années 60 vous répondez que vous êtes
RollingStone
moi oui alors mais on on a le bitles ils
ont en vérité ils ont ils ont fait
beaucoup de choses avant nous euh une
une une année avant ils ont inventé euh
beaucoup de choses qui a jamais passé
euh pour aller en Amérique par exemple
les groupes anglais ont jamais été
populairire en améque avant le Beatles
rien et ils ont montré tout ça et c'est
possible de de le faire mais ils ont
fait beaucoup de choses écire votre
propre chanson par exemple avant non et
c'est très beau le respect justement
dont témoigne votre album ce nouvel
album des Rolling Stones sur lequel on
trouve également Stevie Wonder sur
lequel on trouve Elton John et Lady Gaga
quand on est les Rolling Stones on peut
inviter tout le monde on sait que tout
le monde viendra pourquoi elle pourquoi
ils ils
sont à Los Angeles
c'est c'est le coïncidence c'est le le
hasard ou le hasard et Stevie Wonder il
était à Los Angeles il ami avec Andy et
moi je téléphone avec lui aussi et et
Paul et Lady g travaillent dans le
studio à côté mais c'est tout ce sont
tous là oui mais si vous l'avez choisi
c'est quand même qu'elle a quelque chose
en plus qu'est-ce qu'elle a en plus pour
vous Lady Gaga elle est spécial on est
travaillé avec elle avant sur scène une
fois de fois euh et je connais un ch
très très très
bon un artiste très intéressant mais
mais je suis très surpris ellerive pour
pour
voir dans le studio je je pense pas
qu'elle vait chanter elle arrive comme
ça avec moi et et elle est là sur le
tapis moi et et comme ça je donne les
casques et après je donne le iPad euh
avec les paroles
commence à chanter voilà si vous deviez
collaborer avec un rappeur aujourd'hui
mckjer ce serait qui je sais pas moi
j'aime Dave tu sais de Londres parce que
il il est né dans le quartier même
presque le même quartier que moi
euh j'aime bien lui je sais pas il a
plein plein très bon et vous retrouvez
un petit peu de votre musique dans le
rap d'aujourd'hui parfois oui oui euh
oui j'ai fait une j'ai fait une une une
une chanson un peu comme ça a trè
influencé qui part sur ce disque mais la
prochaine peut-être ce que vous nous
dites en fait c'est que du rock and roll
il y en a partout dans toutes les
musiques et du coup le rock and roll ça
mourra jamais ouais B on sait jamais ça
euh t les gens de musique euh c'est
difficile parce que dans les années
passées par exemple dans les années dans
les années 20 dans les années 30 mais
mais après le jazz c'est le c'est le le
musique le plus populaire le plus
choquante et pour les gens le jazz c'est
choquant pour les gens dans les
années 30 20 mais années 30 ça
plus populaire mais mais
accepter après ça c'est pas populaire
après la guerre c'est moi tu sais et
et peut-être le rock c'est un peu comme
ça merci mer
merci